question first and last name and job
title
hi my name is detective robert siegel
and i'm with the las vegas metropolitan
police department animal cruelty unit
where are we at and why are we here
we're in the 4000 block of east judson
and we're currently investigating an
animal fighting ring
that is occurring here at this home with
what we believe at this time to be over
300 roosters
well the whole purpose of raising
roosters in this regard is to fight them
it's done as gambling and pleasure and
just attending these fights is a crime
in the state of nevada
and raising the roosters and having the
implements
for the animals to fight is additional
crimes and in this case we believe
he is a major player in the underground
gambling
as well as the underground uh animal
fighting rings
because of the large amounts of cash as
well as the large amount of animals that
were on property
and these people that are dressed and
white sits behind you who are they and
what are you doing
luckily we have a lot of volunteers from
the community that care about animals
and they have special training and have
agreed to come out and help us on these
large-scale operations
because we just don't have the ability
in a timely and safe manner
to catch the number of roosters that we
have on this property without the
assistance of outside help
and i'll can you talk about how you
initially were coming here for a
narcotics
search what occurred is uh another
division within the
las vegas metropolitan police department
was doing a criminal investigation
and during the service of their search
warrant here
it was learned that this operation was
occurring and they contacted me to
continue additional follow-up
and can you just name the kind of
charges
[Applause]
fighting roosters and all that stuff
right now the investigation is still
ongoing and as we continue we'll see
exactly what is here
but uh charges will certainly be for
having implements
involved in cog fighting um having the
roosters themselves as well as willful
malicious and torture the animals
for how they are being treated how they
are being housed
and particularly for some of the
surgeries that were done
to these roosters ahead of time for a
rooster to be able to fight you
have to remove certain parts of the
animal um
such as the wattle the crown and the
spurs
so that when the fight is occurring you
don't end up with additional blood that
keeps them from being able to see
and last question on my end what's going
to happen to these 300-plus roosters
well that yeah let me start over i'm
sorry
um the 300-plus roosters that we have
here will be taken to
the animal foundation the goal of the
animal foundation is to try to rescue
rehabilitate and rehome
not just roosters and chickens but any
animal that comes to their facility
oftentimes roosters that have been
involved
in animal fighting are too aggressive
and have too many injuries to be
properly rehomed
but we will make every effort to
rehabilitate and re-home these
how many people have been arrested
currently one person is in custody
only one right right now it's just the
homeowners we believe he was operating
it out of here
this wasn't an active fight that was
occurring this is somebody that's
raining
raising and training the roosters for
fighting
is this investigation gonna take you for
i don't know people that they actually
they buy them and they use them for
fights for
real people that they pay and he
participates in these fights
well what is likely occurring here is
this is an individual that raises and
sells to other people
and then he oftentimes is probably
involved in the fighting himself
so you're going to have a main player
that is going to help transport these
animals in
oftentimes from mexico or other south
american countries
that have a quality lineage so you're
paying an extremely large sum of money
anywhere from several hundred to
ten thousand more dollars for proper
breeding stock that has a history of
being a successful
fighter so this individual is going to
import those animals in
train them and demonstrate their quality
and then he's likely selling them but to
demonstrate their quality
he's also going to be involved in the
fighting aspect as well
so he's going to be taking those
roosters out to fights that are held
both locally
in the state of nevada and even in other
states sometimes
people will travel hundreds or thousands
of miles to get to regional or national
competitions
you almost have to think about it as a
march madness type situation
you start at the bottom and your goal is
to get to the big show
which is some of the regional and
national competitions and those national
competitions
bring people not just from the us but
from countries all over the world that
participate
in animal fighting and then those
individuals will bet large sums of money
oftentimes you have narcotics involved
as well and they travel here for it it
is
it is their sport it is their joy and
that's what the goal is here you start
early in the season which is where we
are now in january
for your final season final portion of
the season which is going to be
somewhere
april may time which is where your your
big competitions are usually outside of
the state of nevada so one last question
one person arrests
which church and what kind of penalty
they could
be looking for the fact that he has the
implements to be involved
in animal fighting particularly [ __ ]
fighting
and the fact that he has all these
roosters he'll be faced multiple felony
charges
related to the torture of the animals
the housing and training of the animals
and having the implements involved in
the fighting